This is "Drew's News,"
your daily fresh coat of the good news paint.
First up, we have to talk
about this incredible desk handmade for us
by the one and only "Restoration Road" star, Clint Harp.
Clint.
Well done.
Well done, Mr. Harp. Ladies and gentlemen.
Oh my God, so good to see you.
Well done, well done, look at it.
It's beautiful.
Oh man, this is great.
Oh my God, Clint, I am so starstruck right now.
How do you think I feel?
You're playing it really cool.
Yeah, you do understand
that I was watching E.T. going, "Oh my gosh"?
(crowd cheering)
Yeah.
Yes.
Really, such an honor.
The Clint "Drew's News" desk is...
I love it, thank you so much for honoring this.
Good to see you, Clint, well done, buddy. You bet.
Thank you, look at our news desk crew.
"Drew's News" at Clint Harp.
Will this fit in the RV?
Oh, I know, I'm like,
"And I'll be breaking it down and taking it home with us."
Let's hit some headlines.
Ross, it's your spray first.
We got a feel-good story for you now
about when a repair project comes in way, way under budget.
The "Good News Network" reports
an old, 14th century church in Grimsby, England,
had a little problem 'cause their clock tower
was just stuck at two past 12 for over a decade.
And they had fancy clock engineers come into town,
they told them it would cost $50,000 to fix it,
but they thought, "Let's try something else first."
So they let two locals take a look, a student
and a local cheese maker,
they went up with a can of WD-40.
Yeah, and they sprayed it, and just like that,
the clock was fixed.
Magic, magic.
Saved $50,000.
That was amazing.
My dad always said,
he'd fix anything around the house.
And he said, "If you have a roll of duct tape
or a can of WD-40 that's all you need."
That is true.
Now is this the dream
to come this far under budget in a project?
Oh, for sure a dream.
And I feel like even just sitting here,
I was thinking about the silos behind us.
When we bought this property,
everyone was like, "You have to paint the silos."
And then when I got the bid in for the silos,
it was either the silos or everything else you see
because I couldn't afford both.
But thinking the idea that we saved so much
by leaving them the way they are.
And now when I look at 'em I'm like,
"I'm so glad we didn't paint them."
So I saved hundreds of thousands of dollars
by not painting those things.
Next up, everyone loves to get a taste of Texas
including wonderful Prince Harry.
"People" reports that he was recently spotted in Fort Worth.
That's right, we love Fort Worth,
attending his very first rodeo.
He went to the Stockyard Championship
and one coach said it was the first prince
he'd ever seen at the rodeo.
Now Chip and Jo, you're Texas royalty.
Have you ever been told
that you kind of sort of have some similarities
with a Harry and a Meghan?
That there's some symmetry there?
I love this comparison for sure.
I also like picturing him at a...
He went from Buckingham Palace to bucking bronco.
Can you imagine him in a rodeo like,
"Giddy-up, horse, yitty-ha"?
That's the thing, I can see them anywhere now
because they're going everywhere
and they're living their dream and they broke out.
And I'm just like, "They're the living example
of don't stay stuck."
Yeah.
So I'm in.
Ross, what's your story?
Next up, "The Wall Street Journal" reports
style is trending westward, y'all.
Clothing retailers are noticing an uptick
in sales of cowboy boots, denim shirts,
Wranglers and lead jeans.
Look, we have a male model right here.
Yeah, baby.
It's about time.
Look at this, pearl snap shirt.
Look at that.
25 years.
Look at that, this can happen in a heartbeat.
That is so funny.
If the moment strikes,
can you take off your shirt that quick?
I've been waiting for you to ask me this whole time.
See? See?
Oh no.
It takes you a minute.
Let me tell you, I would look like a village person
if I tried to wear this, but you pull it off.
And experts say people are itching
to get back outdoors and shows like "Yellowstone"
might be responsible.
I think a good Western look
has just always been and always will be.
I think it's what they call timeless.
(upbeat music)